it's getting very we can afford to spend
more on that if we want to the money is
also there so this is these are some
social choices the other thing is we can
enlist the private sector more I
mentioned the inclusive Innovation
Challenge and there's a 300 company over
300 companies and organizations that
entered and we're going to announce the
winners of some companies they're doing
some very creative things to create jobs
but the government can help support that
we just get a little bit nerdy here
about it there's something called the
Earned Income Tax Credit ro Cana out in
Silicon Valley has proposed to back
travel expanded it's basically a little
bit like the basic income but it's tied
to work so that if you if you work more
have low income jobs they'll supplement
it and it basically takes an $8 our job
and turns into a 12 or a $15 an hour job
not by having a minimum wage which has
the employer pay all of it but having
all of us contribute to it and that way
the employer has no disincentive to hire
the person the employer hires them just
like they did before the person gets
more money and it gets to Max's question
about meaning a lot of people do feel
like they want to be part of the society
in a contributing way and over time I
think people feel more comfortable
playing like our kids do but right now I
think if you just write people checks a
lot of people don't feel satisfied about
that I've talked to some of my
sociologists friends and they and they
feel like having a way to contribute to
society is part of it too but I lose a
lot of those answers let me just stop
there there's a lot more we could do but
let's get some other people you have a
chance next question to your left thank
you both sorry can you hear me thank you
both for being here so in recent years
many people have taken to the streets
and in attempts to solve this problem by
asking people to solve it and every
nonviolent revolution has been stymied
because the people with their fingers on
the buttons also have buttons that they
can push to stop that I see most
technological advances in recent years
as preventing that what do you two see
as the most seamless least violent way
to overthrow the hierarchical
self-reinforcing nature of the
collection of power amongst only a few
individual
can we use artificial intelligence and
the technologies you're talking about
for that and how would you apply them in
this case I think that's a very
interesting question that all technology
is a double-edged sword obviously even
fire and these marks not answer that's
right you use them to you know chop down
little trees and certainly one can use
these modern technologies also for
positive social change I feel that
what's happening actually is that the
the anger that's being felt by more and
more people who see their lives getting
materially worse even though even though
the pie is growing is very very real and
a couple that was with major cuts also
in availability of higher education so
you have a lot of angry people who have
not had the opportunity to learn the
full details of what's actually
happening that's a dream come true for
any demagogues and populist s'right and
I think what we've been seeing here in a
number of recent elections is that
people are just very hungry for change
and they're just gonna vote for whoever
promises the most change Barack Obama's
slogan was change and in a sense Donald
Trump's slogan was also changed because
a lot of people didn't feel the guard
enough change from the warm I think that
the Trump and Sanders both promised a
lot of change brexit was the option that
was the biggest change and ultimately I
think you'll be really really helpful if
people can think of clever ways of
building a social movement that can
actually tap into this these this anger
people show people solutions that will
actually worked
Eric's book Eric's new book machine
platform and crowd that talks precisely
about sort of drivers and businesses are
very successfully used to use modern
technology to be disruptive and I would
love to see some of these same ideas to
be used to transform my society into
something a function add to that very
briefly I mean there's a ton of tools
available for centralizing power but at
least as many for for decentralization
power to giving power to the crowd that
was at least a third of our last book of
my
the newest book was is about whether
it's social media or lots of other tools
for tapping into the millions or
billions of brains we've all used
Wikipedia and other things I just want
to push back on one part of what you
said I'm not sure that the answer is to
overthrow what we have right now maybe
it's because I'm older but I think we've
actually had some institutions that have
been incredibly valuable for creating
power to the people and there are
countries that have used them more
effectively and we just talked about
some of the Scandinavian countries that
do that and if we could restore some of
those institutions that might be helpful
but if we don't I think if we fail to
live up to the promise of the what the
institutions were originally designed
for a hope for then I think we will have
them overthrown I don't think United
States is immune to that and I think the
kind of revolution that we've seen in
many other countries other times in the
United States 200 years ago could happen
here and so the people who right now are
in power should be very aware of that
that if they don't think about ways of
creating shared prosperity then people
will come after them with the pitchforks
like like this guy's going to okay we
have our next question right up here in
the front I think we can address some of
the fears of the artificial intelligence
like turning against us by looking at
the movie wargames mm-hmm the only way
to win is not to play and if we look at
just very simple game theory I mean we
know that the secret is almost always
cooperate and not compete and any
intelligent computer is gonna learn that
right yeah so that's a very good
question you raised there how do you
make people cooperate rather than fight
I think that one of the most powerful
ways to make people cooperate is to
he'll have them all think about the
positive shared vision that they have
which know what why do people agree to
give up a lot of freedom to get married
for example because they have a they
think about all the cool things that
marriage will enable right and this
for all collaboration is because all
parties realize that hey you know if I
put this little petty thing inside and
collaborate I can do this great stuff
now what are we actually doing as a
society when we envision the future kind
of exactly the opposite oh if you go to
the movies and look at the visions of
the future they're almost all dystopia
it's the Terminator or no you name it
right and my wife may I like to point
out that that's exactly the opposite of
what we actually have to do you know I
Eric and I often get students coming
into our offices at MIT and asking for
career advice right I always ask them
wait where do you want to be in the
future and if she says oh I in 20 years
I'm gonna have maybe I'll have cancer
maybe I'll have been stabbed you know
that's a terrible way I wonder have I
sparkling and excited and this is where
I want to be and then you can think
about challenges and how to avoid them
we as humankind need to do that too in
fact that's the key reason why I wrote
my book I wanted to really encourage
people to think about what sort of
future you're excited about the crate
with all this technology and I'm I mean
hoping that this can really foster the
kind of collaboration that you're
talking about but people say yeah if we
actually work together we can get there
that that just seems like the perfect
place to end actually working at the
idea of cooperation and how can we work
together to envision a better or at
least a really positive future so I'm
gonna take the priority here of saying
that we are going to now invite you to
join us to continue this conversation at
a reception and a book signing will have
desserts it's in the museum's cafeteria
so you'll have to exit the theater and
then turn right and then follow the
signs and then ultimately down to the
bottom floor Eric and Max will be there
to be talked to and hopefully we can all
we can all we can all talk to one
another because there's some really
amazing comments
and hopes that were raised here so thank
you gentlemen so much this has been very
eye-opening and amazing thank you so
much thank you sorry
[Applause]
Sunday night on afterwards investigative
journalist art Levine reports on the
mental health industry in his book
mental health incorporated how
corruption lacks oversight and failed
reforms in danger our most vulnerable
citizens
mr. Levine is interviewed by dr. Jeffrey
Lieberman director of the New York State
Psychiatric Institute and author of
shrinks the untold story of psychiatry
mental healthcare as currently offered
by most providers and clinicians
continues to be portrayed as an
unalloyed good an a Lloyd good and
supposedly even more people need to
receive more treatment regardless of the
actual quality unfortunately the Furious
political debate over repealing
Obamacare has obscured the hard truth
that the current in the health care
system is such a fiasco that even having
insurance doesn't ensure good safe care
and what you're saying basically is that
funding needs to be sufficient to
provide services to people but it has to
be good quality care which most of it
now is not right there's been the this
is you as well as anyone would know
there have been discussions over the
decades and various panels and
organizations how do we have meaningful
quality outcome measurements and they
keep offering new methods to measure but
they it's not really implemented and
there's no culture of enforcement and
that's why I have argued that what we're
facing in this country is what amounts
to an epidemic of behavioral health
malpractice even if it isn't
acknowledged as such within the legal
system and that is in part because the
reality of malpractice attorneys is they
don't take a case unless someone's died
watch afterwards Sunday night at 9:00
p.m. Eastern on c-span two's book TV
and you're watching hook TV
Spann - we are in Las Vegas at the
annual Freedom Fest convention joining
us now is author Michael Shermer who is
also with skeptic magazine his newest
book is called skeptic question mark
viewing the world with an rational eye
and he's got a new one coming out called
heavens on earth the scientific search
for the afterlife immortality and utopia
mr. Shermer in your current book a
skeptic you write that those of us who
practice skepticism for living often
find ourselves tiptoeing politely around
the PC police who believe that truth is
relative in all opinions are to be
respected who are those PC police
oh well it's gotten much worse since
I've even written that sentence and and
actually that book is a collection of my
scientific American essays they go back
to 2001 when I originally wrote those
words and it's much worse now than then
as we've seen on the campus protests
going on and disruptions of speakers and
microaggressions and safe spaces and
deep platforming of speakers and all
this just in the last two years it's
gone just crazy and the argument on the
left these are what we call the
regressive left instead of they're far
left progressives but they're really
regressive when it comes to the kinds of
values that we cherish that is
enlightenment values of individuality
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression freedom of religious worship
and so forth all those values mm-hmm
many of these regressive left feel are
forms of oppression patriarchy bigotry
racism misogyny they are ways of
controlling other people so instead of
treating individuals as autonomous
people that have their own rights they
have come to believe that people are
members of groups that are competing for
power so it's a little bit like oh the
old form of Marxism but instead of class
warfare
gender warfare or race warfare or your
your transgender versus the whoever you
know it's it's sort of this competition
of groups this is mostly on college
campuses but they see it as playing out
in the real world so a lot of us have
stood up to this like this is not
acceptable you know it we if you don't
like what somebody is saying then either
come up with a better idea to counter
them or don't go to the speech but the
idea of shutting down a speech because
thus the words that the person may say
are a form of violence this is what they
actually think that you know we're words
can harm people and of course they
immediately go to the the most extreme
version of this the use of the n-word
and that's a form of violence therefore
if you disagree with me on tax policy or
you know some trivial little thing
foreign policy anything then then then
your disagreement with me is a form of
violence and therefore I must counter it
with either shutting you down or even
and most recently with physical violence
as we saw with Charles Murray at
Middlebury where they attacked
physically attacked him and his host who
was a liberal so it's gotten bad I am
very concerned about the future of our
country because these students are
presumably our future leaders
well mr. Shermer how is that a
scientific argument rather than a
political argument well I define science
in a much broader sense than most people
can see though that is not just people
in lab coats but that any attempt to
find a cause-and-effect relationship of
any kind so whether it's the physical
world the biological world of the social
world and so in my previous book the
moral arc I argue that what what the
Enlightenment did was the same thing
that Newton did with physics or that
biologist did in medicine and that is
the principle that there the universe is
governed by natural laws that we can
discover and understand and then apply
to good use so the Industrial Revolution
for example is largely based on certain
principles of physics
and so after Newton published and sort
of consolidation of the physical
sciences then then people like Thomas
Hobbes John Locke Thomas Jefferson and
all the founding fathers they they were
what we would call scientists they they
didn't call themselves that because that
word wasn't even used until the 1860s
but they were natural philosophers that
is they designed the country to be an
experiment very much like a what we
would think of as a scientific
experiment like we have 50 different
states we have 50 different
constitutions 50 different laws say
different forms of taxation different
forms of gun control laws those are all
experiments and we can look at the data
see what the results are and then adjust
our next experiment it's called an
election in which we make adjustments I
I consider that to be a form of science
kind of a social science and the moral
sciences David Hume called this the
moral sciences so I see all the stuff
that that we talk about here at Freedom
Fest that people call politics it's
really a form of moral science or social
science you write that the process of
critical feedback is the lifeblood of
science as is the willingness
however begrudgingly to say I was wrong
yes well the problem is most of us are
wrong about many of the things we we
believe and the only way to find out if
you're wrong is to engage with other
people particularly other knowledgeable
people particularly knowledgeable people
that disagree with you because that's
the only way to find out if you if
you're in the echo chamber the bubble if
you just surround yourself with people
that only believe what you believe if
you only read newspapers that reinforce
what you you already believe if you're a
liberal you read the New York Times
you're conservative you're either Wall
Street Journal you know we all do this
that's fine but every once in a while
pick up the other paper read an op-ed
piece in The Wall Street Journal if
you're a liberal just to see what it's
all about if nothing else if you can't
defend your own beliefs against critics
then how strong are your positions to
begin with so it's a it's a way of
testing your own beliefs and and it's
always possible you might be wrong and
so this is another example where I see
what we're doing is a form of science
because science depends
on peer-review it depends on
collaboration with other people it
depends on other people testing your
hypothesis because we're all subject to
the confirmation bias the hindsight bias
all these cognitive biases that
reinforce what we want to be true but
they may not be true and the only way to
find out is to engage with other people
that's why debate and free speech is so
important in your book skeptic
collection of your recent columns in
scientific America you write that you
want to start a c-span for science yes
in a way well we kind of have some of
that since I wrote that you know the
Science Channel Discovery Channel
History Channel oh these channels do
some science unfortunately their ratings
driven and so they end up veering toward
you know conspiracy theories and Bigfoot
UFOs and area 51 and uh you know it
almost starts to look like Alex Jones
you know it's like hey come on calm down
let's stick to reality well reality
doesn't get as good a rating so maybe we
need a c-span for just science I think
it would sell because science is cool
you talked about area 51 are you not a
believer
oh well area 51 is real it exists it's a
government operation it's a military
base where they test experimental
aircraft for sure that's true but of
course what so-called believers think is
that you know they have they back
engineer the alien spacecraft there
whatever no evidence for this at all of
course you and I we're not gonna find
out they're not gonna let us in if we
drive up there and go down that dirt
road at some point there's a gate and
they're not gonna let us past it and so
we I can't prove that there isn't alien
spacecraft there but neither can you
prove that there is so what's the more
logical conclusion and that is of course
government's keep secrets of course
governments lie to citizens about
national security issues that's true so
when conspiracy theorists say UFO just
talk about governments lying to their
citizens about what's really going on
yeah but so what but that is a mean
aliens of visitors or whatever it is
you're affected conspiracy theory is so
I think it's always good to to keep in
mind the difference between positive
evidence and
I can't prove a negative but it's not
the burden of proof is on the claimant
saying that there are aliens there or
whatever not on me to disprove it
Michael Shermer is there a real debate
in this country about evolution and
creationism well there's a debate
amongst a small group of fundamentalist
Christians who don't accept it but the
vast majority of people of course all
scientists accept evolution and actually
most religions accept it
Catholics for example accept the theory
of evolution it's really only
evangelicals primarily of the
fundamentalist kind that that what we
call young earth creationists there are
other variations like evolutionary
theological evolution that is evolution
was God's Way of creating life okay fine
I don't have a quibble with that
whatever you think is behind the laws of
nature but it's the laws of nature that
we study and they and they're either
true or not regardless of what your
religion is reality exists whether you
want it to be there or not that's just
the way it is but it's it is it ginned
up a little bit in the press the debate
well these things are up every once in a
while most recently with the ark Park in
Kentucky where Ken Ham and his Answers
in Genesis group they already had a
Creation Museum there that I've been to
and last year they opened the ark park
where he constructed this sort of
life-sized version of Noah's Ark and and
and unfortunately he got a bond so he
got some some state money for a private
religious institution which is
definitely in violation of the First
Amendment the US government or state
governments are not allowed by cons of
the Constitution to support financially
certain religions to the exclusion of
others can't do it so when those things
happen it makes the press and it makes
it seem like it's a big thing but it's
for most people it's not
did this issue lead to your next book
the one coming out in January of 2018
the heavens on earth book now that
actually came about from my initially
writing about utopia's in my book the
moral arc because they all why do they
always fail and the reason is people
have this longing for a perfect
paradisaical place to be whether it's
heaven the afterlife immortality or here
on earth where we're going to create an
engineer the perfect society in which
everyone is happy forever and no such
place exists that's what utopia means no
place in Thomas More's original
characterization of it so and I had also
written few of my columns in Scientific
American about scientific attempts to
actually achieve immortality
you know radical life extension you know
radical calorie restriction or cryonics
where you have yourself frozen or you
know you can engineer your telomeres in
your genome so that you don't age as
fast or uploading your mind into a
computer so you can live forever like
Johnny Depp and transcendence you know
these are have long been the realm of
science fiction but no longer there are
many many groups that are working toward
this and they're funded by a lot of
Silicon Valley venture capitalists
including Google Google as a whole
company that's devoted hundreds of
millions of dollars to fighting aging
they treat aging like an engineering
problem to be solved anyway I'm
skeptical of all these things I don't
think it's gonna happen in my lifetime
I'm 62
you know I but I hope I hope they make
it you know I think it's but you know
when they say to me Shermer don't you
want to live to be 500 or a thousand
years huh it's like listen just get me
to 90 without cancer get me do a hundred
without Alzheimer's get me to 110 where
I'm not in a bed with tubes and uh you
know Hospice somewhere just let's just
solve one problem at a time you know
cancer Alzheimer's you know senility
these kinds of things you know just one
step at a time
let's not aim for the you know we're
gonna live 10,000 years uh what are we
gonna do you know how many marriages are
you gonna have how many careers you're
gonna calm down
down let's just work on this one little
problem right here and you know us baby
boomers you know we're hitting the
wallet we can see the wall here it comes
alright we got to do something about it
alright I applaud it go for it man do it
I'm right there with you but let's not
offer something that is not realistic
is there any scientific proof of an
afterlife
no no I'm skeptical of the way
scientists think no there's no evidence
for the afterlife
of course most religions believe in an
afterlife of some sorts but they first
they don't agree with each other at all
there's quite a few different scenarios
in any case there's there's also the
problem of who you are I mean how you
define the self and how that would then
get copied and and then resurrected into
some other format in heaven some other
medium what we how does this work and of
course no one has any good explanation
because there is no and so my emphasis
in the book is whether there's a heaven
or not after this life we should make
this life count the most because the
idea that that we're in a staging area
before the big the big play in the next
life where all the action is you're
gonna miss out on the important things
here and now so thinking about the
Hereafter you might miss the here don't
miss the here this is really important
every relationship that you have every
interaction you have with another person
these things matter now and so I'll make
the most of it when you post your
columns what's the biggest critique you
get well it depends on the subject if
it's if I'm writing about climate change
I get a lot of criticism from climate
sceptics if I write about religion of
course it's a sensitive subject I think
the most mail I ever got from a column
in Scientific American was one I wrote
about an anomalous psychological
experience that my wife and I had on our
wedding day in which it appeared that
her grandfather whose long dead - who
helped raise her with her mom all of a
sudden his radio that had been dead for
decades came alive started playing his
beautiful music just in the drawer where
we left his dead radio and it played for
the entire day and night of our wedding
and then went to
and it's just the weirdest thing and so
I wrote about this saying you know weird
things happen and I can't explain it and
this doesn't mean there's a paranormal
or grandpa was in the you know in the
next life coming through in the radio
but but it's okay to say you know what
that was a pretty special unusual weird
thing and I'm gonna just enjoy the
experience what was your wife's reaction
to that radio she was pretty she was
pretty emotional felt like her
grandfather had was there whether he's
really there or not is not really the
point
it's that symbolically he was there and
she felt you know touched by that and
she's from Germany and we were in in
California and so you know she had no
family there and so it made her feel
like well I'll have family here now so
that's and most of the mail I got was
people that had similar experiences and
some of them were just incredible
stories and you know to all of them I
say enjoy the mystery you know just
because I'm a science guy and I debunk a
lot of nonsense doesn't mean I can't
appreciate the mystery and we don't know
everything you know it's possible that
there there's a another life somewhere
else you know no one knows everything so
let's just keep an open mind don't jump
off bridges to get there you know just
but enjoy the experience why are you at
Freedom Fest what's the connection
connection for me with freedom fella
I've known mark the Skousen the the
owner director for a long time and and
I'm largely a lifelong libertarian if
the youth the word itself the label
itself has become so loaded with baggage
it I hesitate to use it sometimes now
because the moment people hear that oh
you mean like Ron Paul or Rand Paul or
this libertarian or that libertarian
they know it's like I'm not sure I agree
with all those points you know but in
general I believe in free speech civil
rights civil liberties the individual a
right to your autonomy and your own
choices and decisions is the central
core of our where we begin our moral
theory you know I think the Constitution
and Bill of Rights got it right and
those are the kinds of things well we
would call them classical liberals
the word liberal has also taken on a
whole new meaning in the last few
decades different from its original use
so I'm either a classical liberal or
libertarian and the people here mostly
support those those beliefs Michael
Shermer is the author of this book
skeptic viewing the world with a
rational eye and coming out in January
of 2018 is this book heavens on earth
the scientific search for the afterlife
immortality and utopia
book TV tapes hundreds of author
programs throughout the country all year
long here's a look at some of the events
we'll be covering this week Tuesday were
at the New York Public Library in
Manhattan to hear Mike Wallace discuss
the continuation of his Pulitzer
prize-winning history of New York City
later that day we'll be in San Francisco
at the Commonwealth Club where Lila
Jonna will argue that providing jobs for
the world's poor is more sustainable
than aid Wednesday at Regnerus offices
in the nation's capitol it's the
publishing company's 70th anniversary
party on Friday
were off to Detroit to source
booksellers to hear historian taya Myles
examine the role that slavery played in
the city's early history and wrapping up
the week on Saturday we're back in
Washington DC at politics and prose
bookstore where Scott green burger will
recount the life of President Chester a
Arthur that's a look at some of the
events book TV we'll be covering this
week many of these events are open to
the public look for them to air in the
near future on book TV on c-span too
so this is what Churchill faced when he
came to power in those awful days in May
1940 practically from his first day in
office he begged Franklin Roosevelt for
help to stave off Hitler but the
president was very aware of the
isolationist mood of the country and
even though he really wanted to help
save Britain he was very cautious he
didn't want to get involved in this war
if he could help it besides most people
in Washington including him were pretty
much convinced that Britain would be
easily defeated how could it possibly
survive when no other European country
had former US Secretary of State
Madeleine Albright called her our eras
foremost chronicler of World War two
politics and diplomacy and on Sunday on
in-depth author Lynn Olsen will be our
guest MS Olsen's books include freedom's
daughters those angry days and her most
recent last hope island Britain occupied
Europe and the Brotherhood that helped
turn the tide of war during our live
three-hour conversation we'll take your
calls tweets and Facebook questions
watch in depth with Lynn Olsen Sunday
live from noon to 3:00 p.m. Eastern on
book TV on c-span 2
and now on book TV we bring you coverage
from last week's Baltimore Book Festival
we've got a full lineup of authors who
appeared at the radicle Book Fair
pavilion and discussed a range of topics
from gender and race to a history of the
Black Panther Party and the 2015
Baltimore riots and protests first up
its Georgetown University professor
Michael Eric Dyson who will offer his
thoughts on race relations in the US I
hope that you all have had a wonderful
day here at the Baltimore Book Festival
Andrew just joining us welcome today's
been a fabulous opening and we have a
wonderful guest this evening at our
literary salon so just a few
announcements first of all the Baltimore
Book Festival is produced by the
Baltimore office of promotions and the
arts which is a 501c3 nonprofit
organization that serves as Baltimore
city's Arts Council Event Center and
film office we'd like to thank a few
select sponsors who helped to keep the
Book Festival and other Bulba events
free to the public the Maryland State
Arts Council the city of Baltimore
Towson University the able foundation at
aapko the noir Roberts foundation c-span
book TV and Ford our guests for this
evening is dr. Michael Eric Dyson whose
latest book is tears we cannot stop a
sermon to white America dr. Dyson is an
award-winning author a Georgetown
University sociology professor a New
York Times contributing opinion writer
and a contributing editor of The New
Republic and of ESPN's the undefeated
calm he's the author of 19 books
including for New York Times bestsellers
our facilitator this evening is mr.
Quincy gambled who's the executive
director of one Baltimore without
further ado please welcome our guests
for the
[Applause]
come on a Baltimore welcome how is
everyone let's welcome professor Dyson
to Baltimore first of all thank you for
persevering had a little bit of a car
trouble but we're glad that you're here
and welcome back to Baltimore is
obviously a pleasure to have you here
and this book incredible book thank you
sir your 20th one incredible book right
who's already I was really intrigued by
the notion of it being a sermon I'm the
grandson of a South Carolina Baptist
ministers minister and when he would
preach a very challenging sermon he
would say it's tight but it's right and
I think that fits this book is it's
tight but it's right so as we start you
know I you know we sit here in the era
of a trump presidency and race relations
are a fever pitch in this country right
now so it seems that you were either
prophetic or incredibly lucky to write
this book at this time so give us a
sense of sort of race relations in this
country where do we stand and sort of
how was your book fitting in to the
times that we that we're in that right
now well thank you thank you first of
all it's great to be here and be more
and to be with you brother gamble again
and to this wonderful Book Festival we
are not wearing we is wrong but it's
take this this country is in dire
straits right now and not just in terms
of race though that is true and that is
the centerpiece of the fiasco that we
confront but it's also witnessing the
insistence on an adolescent attitude
toward adult issues and beyond that the
resurgence of a neo-fascist
identity in quarters and segments of
culture have been amplified a cold or at
least not sturdily resisted by the top
office in the land and then when you
have the false equivalences between
fascism and anti-fascism and black lives
matter and you know KKK organizations
it's it's truly disheartening to see
where we are I think it's a challenge to
the rest of the nation to catch up to
where people of color and other allies
have been on the left for a while I mean
Donald Trump is the manifestation of
stuff we've been trying to say for a
long time he's like you know bigotry for
beginners in terms of trying to break it
down if you wanted to know what it was
and it is here it is not and I'm not
trying to get into whether Donald Trump
himself is a bigot that's irrelevant at
this stage because what you're doing is
amplifying it and intensifying it and
reinforcing it and I think that we're
living in a kind of Orwellian age
because if you're a black woman on TV
and you tweet that a Donald Trump is
surrounding himself with white
supremacist you got all kind of folk
defending them and the truth of the
matter is white supremacy is as white
supremacy does and so I think that's
where we are right now and we're in an
age where ironically enough
you know I saw Mel Brooks the other day
saying he couldn't make his films
because of this political correctness
that goes on now now I love Mel Brooks
and I love his he's a straight genius I
love his films you know it's true it's
true right on the Blazing Saddles
but here's the thing and he's talking
about the political correctness because
that's what people come at black people
on and people of color women you're too
sensitive it's you're being politically
correct and they asked him where are
there some things you ain't gonna talk
about he said oh yeah you know I'm gonna
talk about Jews dine at the hand of
Nazis and children what damn there's
always a let's let's not talk about that
let's not make fun of that right but in
Charlottesville
there were neo-nazis talking about we
will not be replaced by Jews but they
had Negroes in their scope - how come we
can't get the same recognition why is it
that women of color women's in general
issues women of color in particular
black people's latinos be why our stuff
got to be politically correct as opposed
to off-limits like you shouldn't be able
to say that like that's not something I
should talk about so even an ally like
Mel Brooks in your going like you don't
even get it cuz what it means to be
black in this country is something
deeply and profoundly troubling to so
many people I got a letter for instance
the other day that was funny cuz I knew
it wasn't from him it's it was there
addressed to me from Al Sharpton like
like how's my man we text I don't know
if we got to write me a letter you know
I'm saying so take a letter
Maria address it to my wife y'all
remember that so so it's and I know when
L sharp because was a flowery like
envelope I was like this ain't no al
Sharpton
it wasn't what's up bro hahaha what it
is what it look like
so I opened it look cuz I started
laughing I tell my assistant is name
from our sheriffing
and of course it was from you know
somebody who was quoting me Dyson says
that black people should be given
reparations my wife you know just
twisting my stuff out of term and then
it said bull crap I don't know if we can
say it I guess on c-span and then they
started you know you're you're
ridiculous you're a [ __ ] and the best
[ __ ] are dead [ __ ] I mean this is the
country we live in and I'm a professor I
said you know at this point I'm just
going please call me dr. [ __ ] or or
just can I get a hard for these
credentials yeah can I get a professor
[ __ ] up in here because dude that PhD
is real all right
you know and I and I worked it hard Wow
so that's the kind of country we living
in and when you tell me I'm being
sensitive and hypersensitive and
students looking for safe spaces that
they are being hypersensitive if you
white the country is a safe space
right I'm talking money in general we
know there are exceptions but I'm saying
white folk ain't scared to go to Iowa
not most of you Idaho I went to Idaho
one night and a white man came up to me
and said do you actually think you can
say things like that and live like he
wasn't even joking I was like hey hey I
don't need to hear it but one's on me I
mean so so that's the kind of country
we're living in the left is tired of
identity politics which means it joins
them with the right the lesson they
learn from Hillary and Bernie was that
there are no identity politics Bernie
said it too I'm saying like but you're a
white man your identity is seen as
dominant and therefore invisible and
therefore implicit and therefore it
doesn't have to be articulated as a
specific racial formation and an ethnic
Enclave in American society because you
running stuff and when you run stuff
your identity ain't got to be announced
right so when the Bible says slaves obey
your master children obey your father
woman obey your husband if you that
saying guy you're the slave master you
are the husband and the father you you
got it made the Bible been written for
you the culture is supporting you so it
appears to me that when when the left is
tired of identity politics that's really
strange to me because at the same in the
same breath that goes this is a
referendum by the white working-class
get the contradiction no identity
politics but you're celebrating the
white working-class because the black
working class ain't voting for Trump
right fifty-four percent of eligible
white women did 13% of black men did so
we have some some really disaggregation
of the data to do and when I think about
race not to over answer it we're in a
tough position and some of our allies
have to be brought up to speed as to
what it really means to be a person of
color in America today great answer
before we go for that there's a person
with a microphone so if you have a
question raise your hand I want to mix
this up but I want to just be me talking
to the professor here but I want to talk
specifically about specifically about
the motivation for the book and sort of
what was the process
in arriving I know there's some
intentionality around sermon you're a
Baptist minister for over thirty years
right so talk a little bit about sort of
your process and how you arrived at the
the best most courageous way to to get
your point across was be a sermon yes
sir well I know most people when they
hear don't preach at me I don't want no
sermon I get it
I'm a preacher I know and I don't like
those kind of sermons either when you
kind of Thunder it down and dog and
everybody and say everybody's going to
hell I mean I can't get with that but
this was more than that in the King
tradition oh yes sir that's what I was
about to say thank you for helping me to
that point I was taken too long so I
don't like those kind of service either
but I do like the kind of sermons where
you're trying to orient the culture the
congregation the crowd in such a way
where you're saying this stuff we're
dealing with here is pretty serious and
it demands a kind of engagement with the
social and moral fabric of the culture
that has been sins that has been
stitched with the kind of inscribed by
the kind of vitriol the hatred the
ignorance the disregard for issues of
racial justice and I knew we're living
in a tough time and look to be honest
the book grew out of an op-ed that I
wrote for the New York Times because I
was I'd finish up my book on Obama and
race I was writing another book I'm a
restless writer I got to get to the next
project
and in Alton sterling is killed in
Louisiana his own tape excuse me I'm in
an analog tradition it's it's digitally
recorded the man is accosted by two
police and he's on the ground and they
still shoot him and then I think before
that falando Castile in Minneapolis you
know we know now from the dashcam video
he tells the policeman I have a gun it's
a legal gun as regicide someone lets you
know he's doing everything right
seven seconds later he gets shot so I
was like it's this isn't this is crazy
this is madness this is lunatic stuff so
I wrote an op-ed basically from my heart
to white America saying you got to stop
this so this book grows out of that and
and unfortunately and tragically is
evergreen isn't it because black people
who are unarmed are still dying at the
hands of police we saw a guy get off the
other day their brother Stockley from a
judge we can't get we can't get justice
with the jury and we can't get justice
with the judge and the judge says well
there was no you know first-degree
murder no intentionality let me see a
[ __ ] gonna die tonight I don't
know about you or today I think that's
intentionality you ain't got to be dairy
down Jacques dairy down a deconstructive
practice or Foucault in the insurrection
of subjugated knowledge is to talk about
or Edmond hurts to talk about it with
her to talk about intentionality and
authorial of you know superiority or
authority of the text it just like dude
the man in the car before he stops the
the young man says that an MF is gonna
die today and when he gets out he brings
this person awake a forty seven and a
gun and shoots the man and so the judge
says urban when he's describing him
urban heroin dealer why where's that
what's that part of right so now the
demonization the stigmatization the kind
of stereotypical representation of
blackness meets a judge who just can't
imagine holding this policeman
accountable and in the way that we would
like to see done hands up we get shot
hands down we get shot run we get shot
don't run we get shot speak up we get
shot don't speak up we get shot it's not
who it's not what we do is who we are
and so I wanted to write a book to white
America to say you this wouldn't be
acceptable if this were your if these
were your kids like number one you
wouldn't be going well that's the price
of doing business and statistically it's
a small person you ain't that ain't what
you gonna be saying
right because your child is your child
ain't no percentage in the world is
gonna really remedy or redeem an unjust
murder of your child and it shouldn't
but we know that there are racial
disparities white folk on drugs opioid
addiction let's help them
black people you're thugs you nihilist
you're criminals you're pathological go
to jail right and look across the board
they sent out 350 people half of whom
white half of whom black I don't know
how to divide it that number of maybe I
got the number wrong it's about 300 and
something same credentials trying to
rent a house wife will get the car back
black folk down job same thing same
credentials same excellent qualities
Shaniqua don't get called back sherry
gets the call so we look at the
disproportionate concentration of black
people in prison I don't know a lot of
white folks say well why my god if
you're doing the crime do the time
hey and that's what most black people
think - except white kids ain't doing
the Kratt ain't doing the time right
they end up their victims of affluence
Wow affluenza what the hell how do I get
that how do I get that like damn right
where is the tylenol for that I mean
that's literally an argument white guy
rapes a woman at Stanford he's out in
four months the judge does not want to
ruin his life really though but he wrote
that young woman's life and your ruin
black people and brown people's lives
and the women's lives every day of the
year so I want to write a book to say to
white people I love you I feel you but
we got to stop and you got to be
involved and you've got to you've got to
think this thing now it's tough for many
white people to read because I'm not I'm
not Obama in the game right I'm not I'm
not Barack Obama and I love Barack Obama
that's one style it ain't the only one
right yes we can
you know you talk about his mama he's
just gonna be nice to you in public
let me just say that yeah he he a
brother now he will break a person off
privately so that's one style but that
ain't only style and that ain't good in
the rest of us ain't got bodyguards and
living in public housing on 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue it ain't how we live
in I think he did it this he did a
tremendous service to the country by
being who he is but a disservice in
terms of how he talked about race each
allons-y folk at all now I know he got
to get elected so he got elected then
black people say well then get reelected
then he'll come out like gangbusters
second term yeah not really because
basically that's who he is right so my
point is that I think that's set up
right my Bible tells me if you put out a
demon and you don't put nothing into
demons place seven worse will come and
occupy the house I'm not trying to save
the president who's now president is a
demon I'm saying right I'm simply saying
that Obama didn't necessarily challenge
great white authority and black folk
always defensive him I get it cuz we we
ain't got one y'all got 44 now 44 and we
only had a half a president right 44 and
a half been y'all's half a brother been
ours we protect and a half brother all
we can sew black folk be like mama don't
be talking about him not meant to smack
you
yeah that's baby that's baby baby yes
you know obz I get that but come on now
some stuff he could have done he should
have done and some stuff he said to
black people he should have never said
in public and let me tell you why
because why fo got the notion hey
Obama's talking about how they need to
not serve dick children chicken in the
morning and talking about now I ain't
saying he should but I'm saying you
acting like that's the only people doing
it those are the only people doing it I
understand Gerrans and participles and
so on I want you to know that it's a
deliberative honest eyes articulation
and the postmodern space
uh you know a lot of people doing that
and he went to Morehouse College and he
said ain't nobody trying to hear your
excuses about racism and you got to do
what you got to do and ain't nobody
going you know if you ain't doing your
work anybody gonna get you no slack and
you got to earn what-what they
graduating from college this ain't no
detention center then he went to
Bernhard Morehouse for yo those who
don't know as a black male school
Barnard women's school still
overwhelmingly white do you think he
said looking about trying to hear none
about that sexism and patriarchy the
male gaze we're not trying to talk about
all that stuff we want you know he said
I feel for you now I get it when an
ain't joke group you can be more kind
kinder and gentler as the Bush would say
then your own but here's the thing and
I'll be quiet the thing is when you
jumping on your own you got to defend
your own - now he jumped on us he ain't
defended his left and so I think that's
set up I'm not blaming Obama for Trump I
am holding him accountable however for
his failure to address wasted race in a
specific fashion and Donald Trump said
oh you're not gonna talk about race I
got plenty for you I got plenty of stuff
to say and he has misinterpreted and and
and brought corrosive and cynical
rhetoric to a place that Obama had so
much dignity and intelligence and and
and really an incredible sophistication
and yet he didn't use his bully pulpit
on that issue to the degree that he
could have and Donald Trump wastes no
time in engaging in some of the most
inflammatory racial rhetoric ever that's
that's I think what's going on that's
why I wrote the book to try to get at
those issues and to try to invite white
brothers and sisters to think about
tough issues in a hard way with somebody
who's black telling you the truth not
the [ __ ] not the kinda coding just
the gentle yet firm insistence that
common sense tells you stuff is messed
up and until we come together as a
community of equal citizens nothing is
really gonna be solved well that's good
stuff that's good stuff and our
I know politics so I'm gonna since she
went there we're gonna go there you know
so much of the times that we're living
in have been framed as a reaction to
having the first black president and so
when you when you make your critique one
you have a great deal of credibility so
I remember reading President Obama
saying that when Michael Eric Dyson
speaks everyone else is quiet so I know
he's a he has a great deal of respect
for you so I I'm aware of that so I'll
ask you this so we're all aware of those
moments where he maybe did not hit the
note that you were like firmness it's
okay so give me a key give me your
opinion of when he hit his best form as
far as sure stepping up I would say
Charleston the funeral Charleston was
incredible
the 15th anniversary of Selma he was
marking it man
he was doing an excellent job he were a
mixed company so yes sir I the hell
right
that's like Martin Luther King jr. was
on the phone with John with Robert
Kennedy I mean this off the record right
they were him on them you know face to
feet you know and dr. King was now now
I'm not going to tolerate that kind you
know he's known in Kenny was like you
know look let's be real he said he said
you know that would go over he said you
would be his day if we hadn't helped you
out you be dead as Kelsey's nuts dr.
King was here that silence my god what
are Kelsey's nuts so we're in mixed
company and I have to refrain from those
inside language discourses yeah so the
thing is he was great there he was great
many of the last I think Congressional
Black Caucus because he was also real
bad he was at the VIP I got the victory
lap he was pimping by then you know like
I don't know what you heard about me
okay that's 50 cent the rapper P I M P
is the name of the
in in Obama's case a president imbued
with moral principles so the thing is he
was excellent on many of those issues
when he talked about Trayvon could have
been my son and let me let me let me say
the other side since if I'm asking him
to be honest about the other side I got
to be honest about the other side too as
you brought up and you've lovingly and
gently but insistently criticized me for
that you're right the other side is I
mean the man was was getting hammered at
every moment right now again black
people say well you know if he speaks
about race he go get hammered he's
getting hammered just for existing he
got hammered for wearing a tan suit
right he got hammered for I mean just
everything right hi he's talked I spoke
I walk down Air Force One so you know
it's like the NFL threw the flag no
celebration and football but you see how
crazy I was they brought it back right
they brought it back let the brothers
Cal let him celebrate let Obama
celebrate right if I was watching
football with Shane you know what was
hanging on scores huh you're checking
the scores man I'm trying to keep the
score justice man whack-ass quarterback
starting and and playing y'all in
Baltimore y'all could have done the
right thing huh
y'all could have done the right thing
and what's up with Ray Lewis I know you
bigger than me I'm skirt but giving yo
pants I'm like NAS it you you guys Mike
Vick you you know kill some dogs then
ain't no equality between killing dogs
when I had my trouble you tell dogs
homeboy did not kill anything but the
reputation of an amnesiac culture that
was addicted to forgetfulness and mad
cuz all he doing is trying to say I
don't want my people to be mistreated
now you got you got Confederate flags
out here that are permitted to fly those
are secessionist people they hate your
country they were trying to leave in
we don't like you go away we're taking
our ball and going to our own country
but a guy who says I love this country
enough to try to get it right is getting
demonized so no not keeping score in
that sense at all but keeping score in
terms of what we do for justice so I
think that was I saying when I look at
what Obama I mean Obama did some great
stuff black people say well if he talks
about if he just talked about anything
if he just stood up and breathed he was
he was racially profiled president while
black right presiding while black that
was his sin and that was his crime
so we know and we know in part you know
white folk don't want to face it you
know and every time we say there are
always exceptions it's amazing to me
that people who tell black people not to
make excuses be making plenty of them I
don't mean all white folk I'm talk about
the conservatives who are just like pull
yourself up by your bootstraps and you
got a trust fund
you ain't got no bootstraps you got
silver lining Gucci's you know and and
and so on I'm not everybody
not all but enough to make the point
legitimate so now you know we say pull
yourself up by your bootstraps and so on
and so forth and the reality is that in
this country when Obama is doing what
he's when he was doing what he was doing
trying to make the arguments he was
making people hated him and now we see
that a lot of Donald Trump in the energy
he received derived from the fact that
he didn't like the black man in charge
now you can come up with a lot of
excuses well it was politics and it was
a tea ology and the white working-class
felts